you and Tuan you cannot stop teasing us
with this content we see you get on the
cloak we see the wedding video can you
set the record straight
honestly I'm telling you enough I have
asked I was just like what did we do so
you come like take up because I feel
like we're making everybody go crazy you
know like we can't do that it's just
like it's we can't fans can't seem to
figure out what the deal is between
social media superstars Lele pons and
Hwan the pair is always collabing in
videos and sometimes all that PDA gets
people thinking they're an item but Lele
tell ZT it's actually the opposite me
like and that's why it's so easy though
because it will never win our friendship
because we're so unattractive to each
other I know opposite about what I like
in a man he's the opposite what does
that mean I like Hugh Jackman you know
okay let's have more like Hugh Jackman
man like like just like you can see them
and they're just like tough man and like
you know like tan black hair beard right
so it's like the fair-haired fun is like
Prince Charming and I just need like the
gladiator no any way of putting it
okay you're setting the record straight
just you're just a professional
relationship yes yes
for now Lele is self isolating at her
home in LA during the corona virus
pandemic staying busy doing what she
does best how much new content are you
making what is it like making all these
new videos for Instagram or tic toc
while you're you know can find inside
like you know most videos for Instagram
so now I'm just like sweating it I've
been doing like three years with
disappointment everything I could but
but I've been doing so sorry what do you
think of tick tock do you think it's
here to stay
I think it's here to stay I think it's a
because you know what I think the
beautiful thing about to talk is that
there's so many people that are so
talented and they actually blow up
there's people that might even have like
two followers but their video goes viral
it's a you know it's not like you have
to have colors to be baked no like
there's a there's a lot of people that
I've seen that I've never seen before
they're so talented and as well as I
think that it's cool that everybody's
like doing trends together you know it's
like a whole it's like together.dinner
community yeah community I love making
YouTube videos a lot to like it's just
very different content is very different
house l-like do you have to put on a
different brain switch I do a lot of
trends most friends it's more about
dancing Yannick and I would do like
skits like thought out like skits and
like acting kind of things but this is
like I think more apprentice like it's
just what's going on right now but on
May 19th Lele is debuting a different
kind of content a youtube docu-series
called The Secret Life of Lele pons
chronicling her struggle with OCD my
deepest darkest secret is that I have
OCD
when I first met Lilly she came in as an
emergency situation I just had to touch
everything everything and if I didn't
touch everything like I thought my
family was gonna die I exposed your
story to the world
well I think it's about I mean I'm
someone that has always been trying to
be like someone else on social media
like super positive everything's perfect
life and I think it's about I thought it
was about time now that I'm not really
ashamed and embarrassed I'm having OCD
can I was you know I was because of like
past experiences but I thought it was
time to let the world see my vulnerable
side because they had never had you know
I never and I feel like you know I owe
it to my fans as well because they've
always been so gullible to me and I'm
worried and they're just like I wanna be
like you I wanna be an interesting you
know Kenneth yeah I told him and I feel
like it got to a point that um I went I
met just too many people that had OCD
and they they've told me things they're
like why you should say you why haven't
you said it anything yet then one day I
met this little girl who didn't want to
get treatment didn't want to be in the
center that it was a um where I was
saying and with my therapist and then
the little girl music why what are you
doing here and she's like I'm a big fan
what are you doing here I'm like I have
OCD and she was like you have OCD - oh
my god I have OCD the cheese I keep
trout like she was she was happy that
she had a city cuz I had a speech I was
like I was like no you can be like in
the same club I told her like oh my god
like you'll have a city I was need let's
help each other and she was like yeah
okay okay so I did I feel like it games
people when you when someone that you
admire has it has a good issue that you
have it just pushes you and inspires you
and gives you hope and then you're not
alone I feel like something right now
especially that we all need
[Music]